what's up everybody it's your host
Travis hun back here at 12 talks and you
know what time it
is TR to get right into
it let's get into
it let's get into it first thing we got
going on is me and Lanna we tried on the
uh tried on Halloween fits so what we
got up
there
yes
sir yeah you know we had no fits on put
it on my my favorite one is probably
mski bro it's my favorite one
bro I love that one hosman 2024 I hope
so bro I hope so
uh what we have next let's go to the
next thing we started out making plays
on defense
yeah yeah sh not the ball loose you know
it's three fource fumbles
bro who was our toughest opponent this
year definitely Oregon I don't get to
play but I can tell was
organ yeah shallow knocked the ball out
you know he be coming down hitting cough
it
up made him cough it up that's how it
be yeah no onesie nah no onesie do I
need to start putting back on the
onesies I have so many still I'm G stop
putting back on the onesies y'all I'm
not gonna do that no more onesy next
week onesy next week y want the onesies
back onesies next week man as falling
behind we climb back when Shor found me
deep you know cut your boy the one I do
best man be getting
open we just got to do this more often
during the game just take some shots
that's what we got to
do we need
a we just got to do it bro we just got I
feel like we should just take more deep
shots cuz with me out there it's like a
9010 chance I'm going to get the ball if
it's in there it's
small yeah you know then we got to the
Red Zone you know I finished it off at
the score that was B that was after that
play was after but yeah this play right
here it's touchdown easy walking
touchdown yeah easy and yes I do play 2K
chat I love playing
2K what happened to Bishop here I do not
know I ask him tomorrow for y'all
because I do not know what happened to
us
here am I going to the NFL next year I
hope
so everything go how it's supposed to I
should
be are you saying man no I'm not say
man ma don't miss yeah you know it all
right the camera called Co Kelly getting
fired up in the Huddle lay in the game
let me
see oh no what's
happen oh yeah I know exactly what he
was talking about we let him run the
ball simple we got to come down and
Tackle we trying to play back like they
going to throw the ball they're not
going to throw the ball it's 47 seconds
left that's what he was getting fired up
about that's why he was getting
mad yeah that's how that was he getting
fire because he was not coming down
tack oh also y'all won last week chat is
two and
one this week we got
uh we're going to go to that later but
yeah y'all won last week chat yes
practicing all
week it's time to just go to work tired
of losing now it's time for overreaction
and not overreaction and you
know how to play it so let's get right
into
it all right B gag
Mose this is
zesty zesty
overreaction
overreaction they they were telling me
that Hunter my son has a Halloween
parade at his school where all the kids
at his school they dress up in their
Halloween costumes and they walk around
the track for however many minutes and
the parents come and they video and all
that and I was there for it last year uh
because it was on a Monday and my wife
was telling me that he had that today
and I said well why why didn't you guys
tell me anything about it um and Emily
said well I knew you had practice a
meeting so I didn't think you're going
to be able to come and then my hunter my
son said and it's also because you're
two and six and you need to be in the
office working today they were telling
me that Hunter my son has a over
reaction he definitely a Savage his son
a Savage he Ain care nothing about them
coming to the show at that party go win
some games that's what he telling his
dad it's messed up his son is a Savage
for real though
next kosan is a
Savage I don't know how he put that all
that's a good play I don't know you
can't let this happen I mean qu about
doing the
work uh not overreaction I'm
guessing say scream dead I mean y gotta
talk if y'all want to talk I'll talk
back to yall but y'all not talking in
the chat but yeah what we got
next
right not necessarily go hard yes it
does not over reaction
one 10
s bro I seen
this not a I mean overreaction it's not
a it's not too much that's
perfect that is
great that is
great but like we play like a 4:00 game
Su two high spices with
cheese extra me we got medium fry Oro
mcfur and 10 pce
[Music]
n
nah this is not of reaction that's not a
dangerous pregame meal I mean you know
what your body can take that's not a
dangerous uh pre meal Jackson State bro
I used to eat hot wings before the game
it's not a dangerous pregame Mill hey
you know what you can take you know you
been playing this game he been playing
this game for long enough he know
exactly what his body could take and
what he like to eat and what's his
tradition and what EA what he eating so
yeah that's good we got next a turnover
T is wild
yes not overreaction that is wild buddy
turnover
Tire took the wheels off the
car
what we got
next H my ass no
cap
overreaction some of them are good but
most of them bro they hurt your eyes G
it's hard to
see
yeah yeah buddy
overreaction right there
big
man yeah not overreaction bro this J is
so funny I seen this it's not
overreaction bro I seen this on
TV he was trying to get there yeah
almost got there
too he should have
Dove nah those are the best though bro I
seen a big man catch a pick but probably
is gonna be his first and last pick ever
we got next
oh did he make
it got find the ball yeah never G to
find the ball buddy he missed it you
can't kick a field goal in this
weather not overreaction you definitely
can't bro it's like what what are you
looking at you don't even know the ball
at first of all but yeah another
reaction we got another Monday Night
Football game y'all who y'all got
Chargers Jets chat y'all two in one by
the way what we got what we got Chargers
Jets pull up who you got right now who
you got chat record two and one two and
one two and
one Jets Jets Jets jet Jets Jet Jet J J
y'all know Chargers got a good defense
too
right I can't forget about that that J I
mean that Chargers
defense don't forget about
it ain't telling y'all who to pick for
but just don't forget about that
Chargers defense Chargers defense is
trash okay sound good isn't as good as
the Jet's defense you're
right what you think about s Garner game
he's cold tough locked down you know
seat Bel
Nation Jets by surprise okay why yall
got the Jets
losing who y'all got now jet up jet up
up that's up okay okay
okay and we got five more seconds put
your votes
in jet Chargers jet
Chargers all right jet
one yep jet one 44 56 oh everyone always
asking would I rather do this or that
now we goingon to answer we got a game
or would you rather would I rather
basically so let's
see gr T Hill or Justin Jefferson
both that's what I do for living I play
defense might have to guard both of them
sooner or
later
well Justin
Jefferson first NFL game be as a fan or
player it doesn't matter to
me uh football let football I probably
want to maybe the Super Bowl this year I
might go I don't know
I never been to an NFL game
so I don't know I probably go to the NFL
I mean NFL I'll probably go to the Super
Bowl
game yeah I don't
know one of those three Super Bowls or
be in the Hall of Fame Hall of Fame
can't take that Hall of Fame away three
Super Bowls that mean I could be on the
bench
and win Super Bowls so be a Hall of Fame
be in the Hall of
Fame n of Y setion or TD or P six P six
P
six n touch on is dope too but Pi six
yeah be Batman or
Flash definitely be flash be on that
field I be
[Music]
zooming but Batman got some Powers
though but flash fast though you know
what I'm saying like I can go to the
bank teleport flash
bro I rather be
flash be the mascot or in the b m ah in
the ah
mascot because I'm Bann but they be in
the basement I mean not the basement
they be in like the tower somewhere
sometimes in the away games I definitely
be the mascot been they going
crazy
oh yeah I been going
crazy let's go one one against wble or
yanis definitely WBA y Yiannis Yus
Yiannis will be crazy to
guard definitely wom
though but Yiannis would be crazy to
guard blur someone or snatch their
[Music]
ankles I do a lot of snatching ankles
I definitely say
blur because blur look bad snatching
ankles could look bad too but I did a
lot of
that
definitely blur someone next up we got a
[Music]
blur let's go let's go the first clip
what we got what we got what we
got oh
blur that's not a blur but I could say
that's a blur I guess you might say
that's a
blur oh Mr Harris oh I seen this yeah
blur
blur that's a nice cetch one hand ah
give me that feed and
bounce great
catch
[Music]
oh
blur
blur that was a one hand snag but that's
crazy
[Music]
yeah stuff what we got what it
this
blur Face
Time head
top yeah that's nice one right
there a get off me grap good catch
next
we know he was TR to blur something I
already know who thr it up to I already
knew it was a
blur everyone get head
ta it happens bro it
happens
[Music]
blue oh nice grab t m that's a good grab
that's a good grab y'all know what time
it
is what's next we gotta play the video
pause it and guess what happened
next wait
what
Double D fi goat hey h on
now fake field goat oh wait I said fake
field goal for a touchdown no no no no
no oh fake field goal c c they saying C
is C bro did did you just lie to me bro
you just lie to me
bro bro why do you lie to
me why did you just lie to me bro speed
hold the blocks on field
goal yep look at the quarterback first
of all and look at the receiver he is
not blocking nobody quarter the running
back is running back towards the
quarterback the quarterback is trying to
play it off it's definitely a Flea
Flicker it's a fleet flicker guys I know
it see running back flips back to Caleb
who throws for a
touchdown I can't even see what's
happening oh I seen this
play it's
B I seen this
play I was watching this game you know
we had a late game I watch this
game he just needed one more block
before we out of here you know we host
number 23 Arizona Wildcats this week at
home so we need to get this dub get back
on the right track got to go in there
Focus locked in ready to win we got to
do all the little things right we have
yet to put a full game together have yet
to do the little things right gotta do
the little things right go out there
play be focused locked in defense gotta
come through play how they play and
offense got to come through and play
better than what we've been playing like
so
yeah we just got to get in there play to
our best our abilities go out there be
focused practice we got to practice
great this week it's got to be a great
practice got to put everything together
listen to the coaches just listen to
what they telling us to do and we'll
come out with the win other than that
it's your host Travis Hunter with 12
talks and we out we coming back home
with that dub next Monday and we going
to see who win either the Chargers or
the Jets see if the chat can go three
and one or two and two so see y'all
catch y'all with one be 12 talks we
[Music]
out
a